all right everybody in the conference
room i don't care
if you are gay or straight or lesbian
or overweight just get in here right now
the fundamentals of business the
fundamentals
of business mental is a part of the word
i have
underlined it because your mental if you
don't have a good time
you have to enjoy it you know the the
fun
is in it
get out i know yes so
welcome help yourself um you might want
these orientation materials
wrong toby this is an orientation not a
orientation
okay do not worry all of your questions
are about to be answered cell phones and
pagers off please
oh this looks promising you won't be
disappointed let's face it
moving to a new job can be very
stressful so i have made
an orientation video especially for you
newcomers
but it's not like any orientation video
that any of you have ever seen it's
funny it's got a little bit of a zing to
it
and i hope that it gives you a flavor
of what we're all about here at dunder
mifflin
and what we're all about here in
scranton so let's just all laugh
together
and watch lazy scranton
sitting in my office with a plate of
grilled faker call a man quiet just to
see what we're shaking your mic our town
is dope and pretty so check out how we
live
in the electric city they call it grid
what
the electric city script what the
electric city
called poison control if you're bit by a
spider but check that it's covered by
your healthcare provider
it reminds me of the orientation video
michael showed on my first day
the scranton witch project i am so
scared
when people don't label their personal
food
you like coal mines and you wanna see
him we'll check it out
yo the anthracite museum plenty of space
in the parking lot but the little cars
go when the compact spot
spot spot spot well so far
i think it is killing i thought it would
either be an a or an a plus
but i completely forgot that there is an
a plus
plus i don't think i can work here any
longer
this has been the worst most
backwards day of my life you
misunderstood okay
all right you know what okay
okay i uh i'm gonna put my money where
my mouth is
you ready what are you i am going to
embrace oscar you might want to watch
this angela because you can't catch
anything here we go
now we are going to make a statement you
and i are going to make a statement
together oscar is my friend i'd rather
not and
i just don't care who sees it i doesn't
bother me really would
i really rather not no no
i don't want to touch you ever
considered that
you're ignorant and insulting and small
okay hmm
all right
um i'm sorry michael
i'm sorry
that was a good idea come on come on
all right i'm sorry i called you shaggy
i know
you're not [ __ ] i know you are you're
a good guy you too
michael appears to be gay too and yet he
is my friend
i guess i do have a gay friend you know
what i'm gonna raise the stakes
you don't well i want you to watch this
and i want you to burn this into your
brains
because this is an image man i want you
people to remember
for a long time to come whenever you
come into the office i want you to think
about this we don't need to
yes we do what
oh
i did it
thank you thank you thank you see
i'm still here we're all still here
oh come on dwight come on man there has
been
a lot of name calling against our office
today
corporate maligning slurring much of it
coming from
one of you who claims that prison
is better than here
and none of us can say boo because none
of us have ever been to prison
well there's somebody i'd like you to
meet
somebody else who has been to prison
who can tell you what it is really
like i'm prison mike
you know why they call me prison mike do
you really expect us to believe you're
somebody else do you really expect me to
not push you up against the wall [ __ ]
oh my gosh all right hey hey hey that's
just the way we talk in the clink
but a lot of fun talk about prison today
but i am here to scare you straight
i am in this gay astronaut
in prison you are somebody's [ __ ]
oh and you you my friend would be
the belle of the ball don't drop the
soap
don't drop the soap michael please
where did you learn all of this internet
so not prison and prison at 50 50.
boat look prison stinks is what i'm
saying it's not like you can go home
and recharge your batteries and come
back in the morning and be
with your friends having fun in the
office
what'd you do prison mike i stole
and i robbed and i kidnapped
the president's son and held him for
ransom
that is quite the rap sheet prison mike
and i never got caught neither
well you you're in prison but prison
mike
what was the food like in prison gruel
sandwiches gruel omelets nothing but
gruel
plus you can eat your own hair wow
prison sounds horrible yeah yeah well
thank you andy
thanks president mike what's the very
very worst thing about prison
don't encourage him dwight the worst
thing about prison
was that was the dementors they were
flying all over the place and they were
scary and then they come down and they
suck the soul out of your body and at
height
dementors like in harry potter no not
harry potter
there are no movies in prison this is my
point
you guys got it soft and cushy this
place is freaking awesome
the people are awesome your boss is nice
everybody seems to get along
people are tolerant people who have
jumped to conclusions can redeem
themselves
nobody's nobody's [ __ ] i hope that this
scared you
and from me prison mike to you i just
want to thank you
for listening to me and letting me be a
part of your life today
cause you got a good life
you got a good life a good life
we are going to make a do
not mock
list okay anything that we think might
be out of bounds
we put on this list anything you put on
this list
you cannot be teased about got it
i'm gonna kick it off let's see
what i have to put on the list
right okay i also
have fallen into the fountain at the
steamtown mall
okay who else who else dwight come on i
don't want people making fun of my nose
your nose it's too small
all right oh my that is small just write
it down please
can you breathe okay what keeps your
glasses on hey it's on the list
everybody
no i haven't finished writing did you
sneeze it off
that's it no more okay
who else who else everybody get their
chances i don't want people making fun
of my weight
okay that's too broad it's got to be
something else how about your stomach
yum
you heard it i don't want to say it out
loud okay fine come on up here write it
yourself
and don't sign your name to it and
nobody look
everybody look away look away well i
really didn't want to put it on the
board but i thought maybe it was gonna
come out somehow so
what are you gonna do
okay
you